oh hello word Smith you've caught me at
a bit of an awkward time you see I've
just survived a storm at sea there was a
shipwreck and I clung to a piece of
debris like a barnacle I floated
ashore like a bug on a
twig I've got to do a word don't I okay
uh right let's uh let's do debris
how about
that
debris the S is silent because it comes
from French now this largish piece of
Driftwood is a great example
debris is a noun it means trash remnants
of broken
things I think that piece of debris
floating in the water used to be the
ship's Crows
Nest this word comes from French de
which means to break apart and we can
break that word apart into two
pieces D or du meaning off away or down
and and Breeze meaning to break that's
what happened when a huge wave struck
the ship I was on it broke apart and
pieces of debris floated away from
it all right let's try to come up with
some other related words that use the
prefix d or du and look like the French
word bre all right 10 seconds here we go
I'll put on some
music here is what I came up with debunk
to knock down a bad idea from the
wonderful oldfashioned American slang
term bunkum which means nonsense so to
debunk something is to knock the
nonsense out of it to bruise something
is to cause an injury that discolors the
skin to to crush to Bonk it comes from
the same route as Bree to break debate
this word means to match ideas to argue
its literal meaning is to beat down
debat in French the original meaning is
just to fight but its meaning was
softened into an argument instead of a
fist fight now let's use debris in a
sentence or two after the storm
shipbreaker bay was clogged with flum
and debris from half a dozen vessels
flum is one of my favorite not words it
is specifically sea debris the stuff
that washes ashore after a shipwreck or
a storm but debris doesn't have to be
shipwreck stuff it's anything left over
from when something is wrecked you can
use it figuratively like so sighing
danela picked at the debris of what used
to be a pizza before her brothers got to
it hardly anything remains of that pizza
just the box and a couple pieces of
crust pizza debris some people call
those pizza bones I have never left the
crusts on Pizza I always eat them but to
each their own incidentally in New
Orleans uh if you order a PoBoy a
sandwich with Deb Accent on the first
syllable you're getting gravy soaked
beef they call it de because that gravy
is made with the remains the debris of
other roast beefs it's an incredible
sandwich a PoBoy with Dey we're here for
your sandwich needs and your vocabulary
needs too we're a full service shop here
at con you can learn anything daveid out